aquí tengo un campo vectorial que estoy
llamando como b verdad este es el campo
vectorial b que depende de dos variables
x
y la primera componente es x porque y la
segunda componente es cuadrada - x
cuadrada y de hecho aquí arriba tengo
una imagen que describe cómo se ve este
campo vectorial verdad esta es la
representación o una representación de
éste
desde campo vectorial y lo que quiero
hacer en este vídeo es calcular la
divergencia de este campo vectorial y
también interpretarlo muy bien entonces
nosotros sabemos ya de vídeos anteriores
cómo calcular la divergencia verdad la
divergencia del campo vectorial de por
supuesto depende también de nuestras dos
variables x y ye y esta en realidad se
calcula de forma muy fácil verdad lo
vimos en vídeos anteriores y es la
derivada de p con respecto de la primera
variable que es x verdad y por supuesto
aquí p se refiere a la primera
componente verdad esto sería
de equis y la segunda componente la
llamamos q de x coma de verdad solo para
tener claro de qué estamos hablando pero
en realidad podríamos hablar o poner
digamos cualquier letra aquí verdad pero
vamos a usar p y q y luego tenemos que
sumar aquí la derivada parcial de q con
respecto a la segunda variable que en
este caso es de verdad entonces en este
caso si derivamos p con respecto de x
verdad vamos a derivar esto con respecto
de x que sería una constante y entonces
el resultado de verdad simplemente
derivamos x y luego derivamos la segunda
componente con respecto de y esto es una
constante sea al derivar lo se hace cero
entonces sólo tenemos que derivar ye
cuadrada que es 2 ya su derivada verdad
así que el total sería 3 y esto de aquí
es el valor de la divergencia de este
campo vectorial en cada punto verdad y
podemos notar que en realidad sólo
depende de la segunda variable es decir
de la altura a la que nos encontremos en
el plano verdad así que por ejemplo por
ejemplo si ponemos el valor de igual a
cero verdad entonces la divergencia
sería cero así que si vamos por ejemplo
aquí arriba verdad si vamos aquí arriba
este es el conjunto de igual a cero
justamente es todo este digamos esta
recta es justamente de igual a cero y
cuando ya es igual cuando ya es igual a
cero la divergencia es cero verdad y eso
significa que todo lo que entra digamos
si nos colocamos en algún punto de aquí
verdad y pensamos en digamos cuánto
fluido entrada digamos a una zona
cercana de este punto y cuánto sale pues
resulta que lo que entra es lo mismo que
sale verdad y lo mismo podríamos pensar
de un punto por aquí por ejemplo digamos
aquí las flechas son más chiquitas
quiere decir que lo que entra es menos
verdad pero lo que sale es exactamente
lo mismo y esa es la idea de que la
divergencia sea cero verdad ahora qué
pasaría si por ejemplo no tomamos
pero si no tomamos de igual a 3
entonces regresemos a la imagen verdad
aquí con e igual a 3 tendríamos 123 y si
tomamos por ejemplo un punto nos por
aquí digamos este punto tomamos no sé
alguna
alguna vecindad verdad de este punto
entonces podemos ver aquí que lo que
entra de este lado es muy poquito
comparado contra lo que sale verdad eso
significa que la divergencia es positiva
y de hecho así es verdad cuando es igual
a 3 la divergencia es 3 por 3 que es 9 y
eso es positivo verdad entonces aquí
tendremos que la divergencia es positiva
y en realidad no importa si estamos del
lado derecho por ejemplo estamos aquí de
este lado verdad podríamos tomar una
bolita aquí también vemos que aquí entra
muy poquito mientras que aquí sale
muchísimo verdad sale muchísimo ahora
qué pasaría si tomáramos el valor no de
no de 3 si no no sé digamos menos 4
podríamos tomar cualquier cosa que sea
negativa aquí la divergencia serían
menos 4 x 3
que es menos 12 y entonces al regresar a
nuestra imagen podemos irnos a menos 4
verdad y podríamos tomar no sé un punto
por aquí verdad
tomamos una bolita alrededor y vemos que
todo lo que entra es mucho mayor que lo
que está saliendo verdad entra mucho más
rápido que lo que sale y eso tiene
sentido porque la divergencia en este
caso es negativa y de la imagen en
realidad podemos comprobar esta idea de
que la divergencia es negativa si el
valor de iu es negativo ya primera vista
en realidad no se ve que esto dependa de
solo de verdad pero al calcularlo lo que
tenemos aquí al calcular la divergencia
podemos ver que en efecto no depende de
la variable x sino sólo depende de de
verdad es decir si nosotros nos movemos
en nuestra imagen de izquierda a derecha
verdad manteniendo la misma altura
verdad en realidad pues no aparece que
cambia la divergencia verdad no no
tenemos razón para pensar que podría ser
distinto digamos de
aquí por ejemplo no tendríamos ninguna
razón para pensar que la divergencia es
distinta aquí que acá verdad pero en
realidad esto no lo sabríamos si no
calculamos la divergencia